欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课，同学们 这一节课我们来讲一下 店铺权重怎么样去提升 那么为什么我们要去提升店铺权重呢 因为提升店铺权重能够给我们带来大量关键值的排名的提升 关键值排名的提升是不是能够获得更多的曝光量跟点击量
以及得到更多寻盘转化的机会
如果我们这个店铺比如说从零星升到五星
是不是我们店铺能够得到流量的分配的权益更多
那么我们店铺交易额又高才能达到五星
那么是不是能够让我们的大量的关键词
在同等条件下比同行排名更靠前
是不是这个逻辑
所以说我们做店铺权重是非常有价值的
而且是对于我们整体的一个运营成本是可以有效的降低的，接下来我们来看一下具体的店铺权重都有哪些具体的影响因素，以及我们要关注哪些重点的指标具体商，第一个就是店铺综合分，店铺综合分其实就是我们店铺里面的产品的一些基础数据，比如说有效产品，零效果产品占比，重复扑货因子等等，这些都是影响我们店铺的
综合得分的
那么我们把店铺的基础做得越好
那么它的综合得分就越高
是不是会积累一点点权重
在这个店铺里面
第二个就是星级
是非常非常重要的
这个星级里面会有很多转化率
我们重点看这些转化率
这些转化率越高
特别是高于行业平均
同时接近同行优秀
或者是已经达到同行优秀了
那么你所获得的流量
就会相应的更多
同时呢你的各种关键词的排名
就会更容易靠前
就是这样的一个逻辑
因为它这里是显示的是
营销跟商机转化的一个价值
你的价值越大
那么你在平台上所获得的流量就会越多
接下来就是信保交易额度跟复购跟支付转化率
这里的基本都是转化相关的各种指标
非常的重要
你重点去关注这些指标
然后去对标同行的数据
要超越同行
甚至超越同行优秀
那么你的整个店铺的数据
绝对不会太差
第三个情况呢
我们店铺的类型
比如说你是精品店铺出口通
或者是行业优商
这三类店铺都会有不同的流量分配权益
因为这个已经涉及到你投入多少资本
所以说这里会有一定的区分
第四个就是人群的标签，那么你这些访客的类型好不好，或者是质量怎么样，决定着你最终的一个成交的数据
成交的数据积累在这些标签上面，如果是你本身寻盘很多，但是转化很低，那么你这些标签可能就是效果很差，效果越来越差，后面系统给推荐的这些流量就会越来越差，那么你的整个店铺效果差了之后，没有交易额，是不是权重就会低了，所以说，我们在做店铺人群标签的时候，一定要想办法去做精准的人群标签，获取更多高质量的
从而提升我们的订单转化效果
这样的话我们才能够形成一个正向地环
才能够持续的拉升整个店铺的权重
因为它的店铺权重是会随着你的时间的推移
不断的在这里波动
也会根据你店铺效果来呈现的
所以一定要重视这个店铺权重
你的店铺权重最大最大的体现在你的心急上面
你一定要去重视这个板块
所以呢很多人就是星级可能从四星或者是五星降低到了两星或者是一星
那么你的流量肯定是相对来说会下降的一点点
或者有些店铺下降的非常的明显
这个就是核心的原因了
所以你就没有必要去纠结
为什么我的流量下降
因为你的星级权重等都在下降
所以说流量分配相对的少
这已经是符合平台的一个规则好了这节课就讲到这里希望这些内容能够给你更多的启发去做好店户